there is a Stargate script and it might
actually be in quite serious development
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so the last couple of months we've not
had a lot of really solid Stargate rumor
now I've actually been telling you guys
that's a good thing that means they've
made a decision that means they're not
talking to as many people because the
end of the day the more people they
speak to at MGM and Amazon the more
people that find out about the Stargate
possibility the more rumors we hear
once they've made a decision we hear
less but I've actually had two sources
come to me with some really really
exciting information that really starts
to actually nail down what has happened
at MGM now obviously these are rumors
they're not been confirmed by Amazon but
I actually have two different sources
that have told me that this is true and
that Mark Fergus did produce a script
Before Christmas as part of the
development work he was doing to sort of
show Amazon what he would like to go in
a direction he'd like to take the
project
no
who shot me
script that he produced though wasn't
for a movie that we think we're going to
be getting it was actually for a
two-parter opener to a new season of
Stargate I can tell you that it was
going to be an sg1 Revival
it's wonderful
together
we should celebrate now there were some
actors that were going to be brought
back from the original series but the
script I'm told was based around a new
sg1 team I am told Amanda Tapping as
general Samantha Carter what's going to
be returning I mean
I know where you come from you're
considered relatively intelligent at my
Galactic standards that's not really
saying much
wouldn't you agree
I'm told that Michael Shanks as Daniel
Jackson was going to be returning in a
new civilian leadership role not quite
sure what that means but it could be
lots of different things
look all I know is that the place you're
searching right now is not it
then where is it
did I just say all I know
everyone turn away
I want no Witnesses
Richard Dean Anderson was going to
return as a retired General but he was
only going to have quite a small part to
be honest lots of this sounds an awful
lot like what we think we're going to
get from the Brad Wright script
potentially or at least the Brad Wright
movie that we were going to get
take a break
Frazier says teal needs a little pep
talk
I've been practicing in front of a
mirror for an hour
not happy enough not really
I also hear that Ben Browder was also
going to be returning as Colonel
Mitchell or General Mitchell by now I
don't know I know nothing about your
fair planet
other than it seems to have a rather
interesting if somewhat limited gene
pool
there were also a couple of other little
cameos from other people but those
actors are actually going to have quite
a prominent role in this two-parter now
the very interesting thing is that
apparently some points in the last month
to six weeks Amazon have asked for that
script to be reworked into a movie
script now it's not 100 clear whether
that's Mark Fergus going to be doing
that work but I'd be very surprised if
it wasn't and I have to give you a word
of warning this doesn't necessarily mean
this project will ever get made we don't
know lots of what's going on and it may
be that they're developing a couple of
scripts to sort of compare and contrast
with while they make the final decisions
but
if an announcement is as close as we
suspect we're thinking hopefully that
we're going to hear something official
in July at the latest at the end of July
we're thinking San Diego Comic-Con but
really within a couple of weeks of the
writer strike ending I firmly believe
that we're going to hear something I
hope so anyway
[Music]
I do know this
we need to put together a team starting
with the most beautiful battle-ready
scientific genius I know
Captain Dr Samantha Carter
but if that is true then Amazon really
must be a little bit further down the
line than we think I.E they must have
decided to the partner is that they're
going to make this with
a big Studio partner we're thinking I'm
the Warner Brothers I think Warner
Brothers or possibly Sony or maybe
smaller Studio we'll have to wait and
see I also think though that they're
going to need that development partner
I.E we think penguin in a Parker with
Mark Fergus
if that is correct then it'll be Mark
Fergus that'll be reworking his already
existing script as soon as the writers
strike ends and is allowed to into a
script for the movie now
this is pretty awesome because this
means that we're actually going to have
a storyline we're going to have an idea
what the plot might be and we're going
to be moving towards an actual
um production schedule very very quickly
it also means that actually a lot of
this work that needs to be done to get
this on our screens quite quickly is
getting done that they're actually
taking advantage of the right to strike
in some ways and actually get in all
their ducks in a row
it also means that I very strongly
suspect that they already know who the
director is going to be but I'm going to
talk about that in another video because
I might have some names for you
so a script exists we have some idea of
what that script involves we have some
idea of some of the returning actors
that we might get to see and we have
some idea of a runtime in a way because
it'll be about two hours
so guys I'd love to know exactly what
you think about these Revelations
is it exciting to you that they're so
far along because let's be honest this
has been a roller coaster of a ride it's
taken us a very very long time it feels
like to get even this far I've been
telling you exclusively and first lots
of stuff about what's going on behind
the curtain Amazon but now we might be
about to actually get something real
tangible and official that we can bite
our teeth into and it might just be very
very close to that announcement date
most importantly I've actually really
loved to know are there any actors not
mentioned on this list that you would
like to see so Amanda tap in Michael
Shanks Richard Dean Anderson in a small
part and Ben Browder who are they
forgetting about
indeed get to the comments and tell me
exactly what you're thinking if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
hit the Bell notifications you never
miss any of our new videos I'm certain
you know exactly what to do and as
always please stay safe and I'll see you
next time
foreign